[Music]
welcome back to the jewelry podcast
brought to you by mothers shouldn't be
real he's so soft too just like me and
these guys this farm you knees go to me
undies dot-com early first anyway Julian
to get your 15 percent off of your
beautiful pair of me undies and guys
Valentine's Days coming up okay what a
better gift and Mandy's also Squarespace
you looking to build a website for
whatever your hobby your business your
online shop your passion project doing
Squarespace it's very easy and they make
it a very fun to do and you get exactly
what you want with all the templates
that they can help you with you save 10%
when you go to Squarespace comm /
annejulien
or click the link below thank you
sponsors yeah we've talked about it
before but like Marvel had his teeth
taken out and he looks cuter now like
he's just he looks different like a
significantly different cuz we look at
him every day so we can tell but he
looks cuter it's like he's weirdly just
like looking at me straight up yeah he's
it's not fair it shouldn't be real he
never was that's cute I mean he was
always cute but always this cute alright
I'm really sorry okay you're having fun
you smell like lavender because I just
put some essential oils and you use
essential oils a humidifier
it's so nice we have a little one like a
little diffuser downstairs it's just
like so nice to put yeah cuz we O's used
to light all those candles and then I
said no no more candles after you know
the 70th time Julian has fallen asleep
and forgotten to blow out a candle and I
said we're gonna burn down
okay you know either get a candle warmer
or we're getting essential oils because
I don't want to burn down you know what
I'm saying I think we should invest in
non essential oils just because if we
lose them it's not only lost anything
that was essential to the operation can
we go back to the shark tank really
quick I want to pictures okay you ever
get sick and tired of being the anxiety
that you get from potentially losing all
of your most essential oils absolutely
not me too well now introducing non
essential oils there are oils that are
literally like literally identical to
essential oils but we put an on in front
of it so that you don't have to worry
about losing them do you work for
someone who care who makes you have a
lot of essential oils and you're afraid
of getting fired every day is the
nightmare at work bring some non
essential oils low risk low reward baby
I'm just gonna take some deep breaths
and stress stretch my neck out until
you're done with this you're gonna rub
some non essential oils on your neck
while you do that do you God me give me
the strength to deal with my every
boyfriend you know I looked up because I
was trying to think of an idea for the
podcast I looked up if it's possible to
change your sign I don't think it is no
it's not but it should be and there was
that article floating around like a
couple years ago like every once in a
while it resurfaces and people tweet it
at me non-stop they're like you're
actually a Libra right now or someone
like this a good chart change yeah the
planets shifted or something and I'm
like planets know like you know what if
they are right what if you know
seriously what kind of identity crisis
would you have if you realized that you
were no longer a Virgo as with me as an
Aries
it would be intense I wouldn't have an
identity crisis I would just not I'm not
like that I'd have to look inward what I
think you would be exactly the same and
exactly who you are but doesn't that say
something fiery tornado doesn't it say
something about maybe how if the
astrological chart can change like that
but you still are the same that it holds
less water
I don't know Jillian all I know is that
whenever you make something to eat all
of the ingredients are all
the kitchen yeah but then you know
there's a fantastic creation wait how
long how many banana bread ingredients
are in the kitchen right now I made
banana bread today I didn't check but I
think you cleaned up after yourself uh
all that's left is the butter there's -
butters sitting next to each other why
did you take out both containers of
butter and put them next to each other
on the table because what if we run out
of one moment can you tell me like thank
you so much for making banana bread it
was so delicious always a good time how
it came out so mushy was it because it
said baked for like 17 minutes and you
bake for 12 but it says use three really
ripe it in and smash them up I use the
four and a half we had extra I didn't
want them to go to waste so then you
need to make the recipe a little bit you
know I tried I threw an extra little bit
of flour and salt I don't think it works
like that well it's not baking because
it's banana well you know what I got a
lot of concert complements on my
Instagram my story people who said they
wanted some so I think it did really
well I thought you had just under baited
on purpose because you were hungry no no
I put about for the record okay I didn't
[ __ ] up this recipe I put it back in the
oven and I'd be like you guys stay here
for a little while until you get a
little brown on top and there's the
toothpicks coming back pretty dry uh-huh
sure I like my sense of humor Kermit no
crying welcome back to the Kermit no
crying podcast we ate some banana bread
and we listened to off the pill right he
does such a good podcast he said y'all
gonna grab sleeps
dude I Love Lucy and graben sleeps the
more I hear the word grabbing sleeves
the term it sounds good
it sounds like it could catch on grab me
like when you use sleeves grabbing
sleeves dude yeah I know what guarding
sleeves is because you always do that
and then shout wrist control
in my face do I all shout at you I don't
shout in general very quiet person what
sleep what grabbing sleeves means is
like in jiu-jitsu you grab you know you
grab each other's key and there are you
grab the lapel and you grab the sleeves
and I think what happened was like
twitchcon we me and will we're like
joking around he was like we should grab
some sleeves and I was like dude but
anyway yeah Ryan he can and will and
Paco launched the podcast called off the
pill and they fought will they finally
officially made it a podcast and I'm so
excited because we [ __ ] camera angles
beats yeah three camera angles poor Greg
that sound like Greg's computer was no
it looks really good and it sounds
really good so someday we should podcast
collab we should podcast collab I mean
we should hang out we should go to there
we should go to Ryan's house and podcast
for their podcast and then halfway
through I'm just gonna turn on a
recorder and be like can we Calabria
Leigh click no it's super cool it's
super cool and like if like an Internet
friend starts a podcast because I feel
like I'm always looking at like for
about guests you know when you're so
nice to put on and just have in the
background what you're just like hey you
know yeah I was looking at pictures of
plants eating banana bread and listening
to off the pills that's honestly what I
like to call a sick Sunday that's what
I'm saying yeah I was kicking it I was
just grabbing sleeves
no you weren't you didn't grab any one
sleeves moving on your own that just
reminds me of this kid that I went to
high school with but like at every
school event he would put on a
straitjacket and gather everyone around
so he could get out of it yeah whatever
he was a couple years younger than me he
was just like all right everyone gather
round I'm gonna get out of the
straitjacket we're all just like Josh
dude you do this at like lunch sometime
like stop we know the trick you just get
out of it
18 on your shoulders out and then you
[ __ ] get out of it I'm so tired of it
that's what I like too
that's not like all being committed to
the joke you know he went for it over
and over and over every event that was
his bread and butter he knew it too was
like not that big we've all seen you do
it for him
well I mean all it takes is one like
gasp that sticks with him forever and
he's like damn I made a difference
people are blown away by this I need to
keep doing it that's his purpose yes
nothing against magic like magic is cool
but like you can't have one magic trick
talking about magic they are sometimes
overwhelmingly creepy but when they're
good magic then yeah I think there's
like a stereotype of like you know
creepy we like weird people who do magic
[ __ ] corner you well so that's the
magic that's just that's a whole
different thing because that's that's
called just like being a rude person and
having the hobby of magic so you can't
blame the hobby for rude people but that
is really annoying
yeah like I'm sure there's rude people
that work in car washes and there's food
there was like some magic youtuber who
came up to us multiple times at one
thing and wouldn't stop doing and we
just never wanted to be a part of it
just kept happening and it just felt
very like non concession that that's an
essential part of being a magician is
understanding when your audience is done
seeing that yeah like like your fears
it's such a strong sales pitch you're
you're like being so like pushy as a
salesman you got to just trust your
magic dude it's like if you're if you
have trying to sell a product like I get
you need to make the sale but if your
products good it'll speak for itself
you don't need to be annoying I wish
that when someone was doing magic to you
they'd give you like a choice like would
you like to watch a 30 second magic
trick a 1-minute magic trick a
two-minute magic trick a 10 minute magic
I feel like I've gotten roped into like
20 minute magic tricks and I'm like yo
where is this going
I need a snack like I got I gotta go
drink some water candy I wish you would
have given me a heads up just how long
magic was gonna be yeah they're not
sensitive to other people not having you
know all the time in the world when can
I be amazed and then like we go our
separate ways
well just like yeah that would be that
would be courteous I think anyways when
I said grabbing sleeves that just
reminded me of that one kid because
always can you put him in his bed permit
going you do a magic for 30 seconds all
right watch I'll put marbles down in the
bed and then he'll go sit down there to
know he's gonna jump up on the empty
spot now on your lap try to jump up he
made the he made the attempt jealousy
cured no okay so what are we doing you
have you ever had someone corner you to
do magic at you know I don't for you I
don't get cornered like you do I get you
get cornered you are like the nicest
person to touch a fight sometimes okay
I'm gonna say it like okay the people go
to your door and asking to have you
complete the census right they like they
pester you they solicit they call you
and they've been coming to our house
like asking us to do the census and
every time they come I'm like no thank
you
you know by I don't say come back later
I don't say whatever you know I've I've
had like a couple kind of rude senses
you know people be like you know um you
know well I have to take your name down
so I could tell people that you refused
or like some some passive aggressive way
of like accepting me saying now or
whatever so they like you know come and
the other day I like notice Jenna's not
in the house I'm like well I'm like wait
I'm like I was on my computer and it
just got silent like the dogs weren't
running around I was like where where's
the no noise so I get up and jenna is
nowhere to be found I look out the front
and she's talking through the game to
someone and I'm like this isn't right so
I walk out there and she's doing the
census she was cornered to do this
she's like the nicest person you're
you're like someone says like hi could
you please and genis like done easy I'm
gonna do it she's like to a fault you're
so nice and you want to please people
she's doing the census she was probably
out there for like ten minutes before I
even got there so I'm like wait what do
you like you're doing the census right
now and she you look at me and you're
you know you're trying to be nice you're
like yeah like and I know you don't want
to do it so I'm like you know that takes
like 30 minutes to write my radio show
to you it was a workday I was like we
were turning it [ __ ] done
oh yeah I was like editing or something
and I was like you know it takes like 30
minutes and you're like oh yeah but um
you know I'm just trying I'm just like
doing this on a front yard it was really
funny because he was just like oh you
know cuz he's been here non-stop like
every day I don't really understand how
it works
I don't either maybe let me know in the
comments if you guys know how this works
because I'm confused and Brett said the
same thing
Brett said that one of the census people
showed up his old apartment and did the
same thing like she just kept coming
kept coming so one day he gets a knock
at the door and there's a little girl
standing at his door you can see through
the peephole so he opens the door and
the census lady steps out from the side
like she had used her own daughter as a
way to get people to open the door -
then sidle them into doing a census and
I don't know I don't think you're
legally required to do these in-person
interviews because what he was saying is
that it was for health care or something
and you know do you want your tax
dollars to go to X Y & Z so I'm sure it
serves a purpose but I don't think I'm
legally obligated to do it in person
survey like that about health care you
know yeah but like there's so many other
houses I'm interested why one census
person will just sort of found your
house non-stop or is it our entire
neighborhood or is it just us you know
supposedly it's not a prosecuting
offense if you refuse the census I think
I don't think you'd get do you get a
fine or maybe I think technically you're
you're subject to a small farm but I
think they don't prosecute for that
it's good to know but it's like I get it
if you can
I'll do it online or something like
whatever just like stop coming to my
house yeah it's just soliciting at that
point but he was really nice and I
really liked him and he was laughing and
he kept trying we got to like the second
question because he couldn't read his
laptop and the son his father coming in
prepared in his perfect world he he
rings they are in fill it in later in
your lap like he knew that scenario it
was the best case know you were gonna
say yes and you'd have to do it out in
the world and he still came yeah because
I was like it super-quick could only
take five minutes and then I was out
there for like ten fifteen is a thirty
minute process and he can't read his
laughs passive-aggressive census agent
who told me that I was a bad person for
not doing it told me it's a thirty
minute process thirty minutes
that's I feel like it shouldn't be a
thing where census person calls you a
bad person for not well she didn't say
you're a bad person but she was when so
many words she said yeah it's not nice
well you know what some people aren't
nice some people just are having a bad
day or don't don't want to be nice I
don't even know well I was just trying
to do as a solid so that you know then
he would stop coming back oh but you
were trying to go to your package and
you got cornered that's what you were
doing would have a nicer I guess if he
was like watch me get out this
straitjacket teehee no thank you
I'm a small amount of applause and then
go inside anyways yeah I do get sidled
very often by people and then to fault
that comes from the best place in the
world you're like amazing and nice but
it gets you into hijinks yeah get in
trouble so you get in the hijinks yeah
low jinks I do get me a cook no I don't
know you
jinx jinx that's all if we say something
centum what podcast is this
I'm speaking with me over my mouth
Jason no you can't say a mouth you owe
me a cactus cooler gee I don't even know
where to get a cactus understand this
you don't know what a cactus Coola no we
didn't have that that was such a big
part of my childhood I don't know man I
gotta think about some things
no I'm joking oh we were talking about
like we'll about it no I had Capri Sun
yeah I did everybody I could press on
and did you Rafal that man into a cell
phone
someone in art no you never did that
[Music]
when you were called the box wine and I
don't Caprice that's good the wines in a
bag inside oh yeah
so what you do is you take the Capri Sun
pretend like this is the Capri Sun this
is my cell phone but pretend as the
Capri Sun remember this is actually a
cell phone but we're pretending it's a
reason you put the straw on the top
right and when it's flat and deflated
and you drink everything you fold it
this way it's hot dog ways I can't
folder because it's a cell phone and
then you fold it up it would turn into
like a flip phone right and so then the
antenna is the straw so you pull up the
antenna flip it and then you're a loser
like I was yes I'm still loser okay bye
and then you draw the numbers one two
three seven eight nine you know the
numbers mm-hmm I was going somewhere oh
yeah cactus cooler if you've if you know
about crack cactus cooler you might dude
if you don't I don't understand your
life we didn't have that like otter pops
I'm talking about a soda yeah I wonder
why
maybe it was the West Coast thing it's
root beer that's a type of drink yeah
yeah Brent y'all ever tried rupiah
before though damn she's hot Wow sick
the cactus cooler distinguished by his
orange yellow and green label with a
saguaro cacti is an orange pineapple
soft drink sold in the US Maine mainly
in the Southern California area there
you go there's your explanation as to
why you're so mad at everyone for not
knowing what cactus cooler is it was
only specifically in your region
she'll come God is really good [ __ ] I
did the first time I came in California
was like an adult damn that's crazy well
no actually that's not so much time as a
kid here I visited San Diego one time
because my godmother lives there huh san
Diego's cool I hid as a California
native I have not spent nearly enough
time in San Diego I've been there like
three years what is that thing where
people from Los Angeles don't go to San
Diego and people from San Diego don't go
to Los Angeles the thing there two hours
apart yeah but I feel like it's not a
thing where people are lobbying people
go to Palm Springs Big Bear I don't know
I I think it has to do with if you live
in San Diego it's because you love San
Diego like it's uh
I don't know if you like it enough you
live there you don't go there sort of
thing people why don't more people just
go to like hang out I don't know that's
what I'm saying like I I went there once
when I was in college cuz like a buddy
of mine like a flatmate had a friend
down at San Diego State and I had a
stepbrother dad's new neighbor say so we
made the drive down for the weekend and
we like did college parties you guys
made your bed into bunk beds cuz your
stepbrothers Wow
just cut that out we'll cut that out
so I went there once in college didn't
really have a good time at all
why didn't you have a good time because
everyone was drunk around me and I just
I don't know I wasn't fun
I wasn't a big college partier and I
went down with you well I went to
Carlsbad which is almost San Diego and
then I went down one more time but I
I've always wanted to like spend time
and linked what is it the Gaslamp
District oh and like I've been to a
Padres game once it was fun I went there
with my friend Kim really wanted to go
down there when she was visiting from
Boston so I took him down there yeah and
then another time I met Jackie because
she was doing like a fitness expo or
something mm-hmm and I drove all the way
down there to meet up with her and I
forget what happened but basically we
couldn't really hang out because it was
could you ask her I'm kind of curious
now I want to know what happened I want
to know the story I don't really I don't
remember I just remember like her
texting me that she was like sleeping in
a hotel with like her work people or
something and I'll meet you in the lobby
and I saw her for like 10 minutes and
then she's like all right I gotta go to
bed I'm like why do I come home oh my
god funny Expo sick yeah anyway San
Diego be like fun though yeah I mean if
I'm thinking about taking like a day
trip or like a two-hour like a one to
two day little staycation in California
I'm thinking Palm Springs I'm thinking
Big Bear
Timmy is not like at the top of the list
which I don't know why I mean me it's
just a different experience you know
that's like not you're not secluded
you're in like a city and it's sort of a
beach town I think right I have no idea
I do want to go to that bird place
though the bird sanctuary because I
can't have a bird and I know it like a
parrot like one is you know very fun and
lovely and can live 80 to a hundred
years or whatever the [ __ ]
crazy they have a place that rescues
birds done that I want to go and visit
because I adore Birds we were trying to
fight [ __ ] adore them Beach I know I
know you do you love your burbs
we were trying to figure out a place to
go to film when I was shooting the Sony
video with the new camera and that was
our number one choice you're gonna go to
the bird sanctuary and I called and we
actually had made the decision the night
before we woke up early as [ __ ] and we
were about to get in the car and I
called just to make sure and they were
closed like [ __ ] like thank God I called
so we ended up going to the one in Santa
Clarita but I would love to go to the
bird bird one sometimes I love it so
much be cool to look at them all I do is
watch bird videos on YouTube have you
looked at their website it's pretty nice
I think it's designed by Squarespace
weird speaking of which this is an
awesome website building service that
you can use to build your website
whether it's personal or business it is
great they have amazing 24/7 customer
support to help build the website that
you want you're not cutting any corners
it's very easy it's user friendly but
you're gonna make this look like the
website you always dreamed and you don't
have to learn how to code or anything
like that you make it look good on
desktop mobile on tablets you have
control over every little thing you can
build online shops and stores built into
your website really nice it's it's kind
of sells itself honestly if you try it
out what you can do do a free trial when
you go to squarespace.com so I'll show
to Julian you also get 10% off if you
decide to buy a website or domain you
realize all the different tools they
give you in the process of trying to
build a website and how then it just
becomes like a really fun project
because you're customizing it and you're
not worried about you know the technical
stuff they're there for you literally 24
hours a day to help you if you're trying
to build a website that looks like you
know maybe a website that exists you can
have certain websites as inspiration and
then bring them to the table when you're
trying to build yours and use them as
inspiration but they have so many
templates as well that you can start
your website with so check it out
Squarespace comm slash annejulien
for 10% off or you can just start a free
trial see how you like it also
continue to tweet us your website URLs
because I've seen a couple great ones
like the nasty place that Jeb Bush built
for the first sermon
it's Kermit's own website pretty much
it's just nasty pictures of Kermit I
know
Squarespace also guys me undies is in my
opinion the best Valentine's gift you
can get your loved one this year it next
year I'm gonna pitch you the same thing
next year because it's great micro modal
fabric is what they're made of three
times softer than cotton you can get a
style that fits you but also your loved
one you can get paired style so you buy
them in pairs which is really nice
because they're matching and it's like
his and his or his and hers and you get
romantic and nice and the most important
part is how comfortable it is so if you
have never worn me undies I suggest you
giving it a shot and what a better time
to do it than Valentine's Day they will
be releasing a new print every Tuesday
and they have new prints all the time
they work with artists it is it's pretty
fantastic and they have some really nice
Valentine's prints as well already out
so get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies in the world right
now and go to me Andy's calm / - no
Julian or click the link below also me
and easy just built off of wonderful
people good team over there yeah
hmm what do you mean hmm you wanna see a
magic trick
yeah give me a I don't have I got five
minutes I don't have any you know what I
just thought of this what if we built an
app you think how much time do you have
for magic where you can book magicians
but for certain part time periods mm-hmm
it's like the fire app wanted to be just
not a complete absolute disaster of a
[ __ ] show yeah so you want to book a
magician I'm gonna call it I'm gonna
call it magic
ma ma gik with a little swig li line so
it looks futuristic in like uber you go
on to the magic gap how much time do you
have five minutes
ten minutes this was your ID I stole 20
minutes an hour that'd be great for like
a kid's birthday party
I want an hour magic show okay a clown
or a spider-man birthday party performer
hat where you body it doesn't I also
just got a patent on it and what
wouldn't exclusive for magicians though
and I want it to be like people can read
like leave reviews on them
magic [ __ ] that's pretty good that's
pretty good do you think
speaking of reviews do you think people
get like there are people who go around
reviewing things on Yelp as like a job
honestly they probably maybe not is a
job well I mean if you want to be real
conspiracy theory I'm imagine there's
plenty of companies that would pay a
person to write them a good review like
they go on Fiverr they're like I'll
review your business yeah oh god you
real nasty sore like plenty of companies
just pose themselves as customers and
pretend and then review I'm gonna spill
some tea I knew you were gonna spill
this I'm gonna spill some tea I'm not
gonna say any names I won't say any
names or companies okay this is so
fantastic though I couldn't believe it
was a nice detective work okay oh man
I'm gonna try to be as vague as I can
because I don't want to name anyone or
anything and this is not even that
serious it's just kind of a funny thing
I found but there is a certain company
giving certain things to certain online
people right and I heard about it
because you know a couple of the online
people who they were giving things to I
knew and I saw them getting these things
and I thought wow interesting and I was
very close to getting connected
I was already connected I was very close
to actually pulling the trigger I'm
saying sure we'll take some - turns out
I was just kind of bored so I decided to
do a little research also because the
interactions felt a little off between
me and the representative of that
company
and so I was like you know it's kind of
weird like just the whole interactions
just felt off something about it so I
did some research and I looked up the
name of the person who was trying to
kill me this product who worked for the
company and the name of the product and
like I was just googling it and I found
this reddit thread where well I found
multiple reddit threads but I basically
found reddit threads where this person
with the same name in last initial it's
not a common name or less initially yeah
so it was like birth imagined like
Bartholomew W that was the name and last
initial and that was the name and last
initial I got on my email so I was like
that's what I'm talking to so I searched
their name and I found on reddit so many
different threads pop up with the same
name and last initial and that's their
reddit user name they didn't even like
hi there my user name
and it's them going into different
forums that we're talking about said
product trying to casually promote it as
if they are a consumer like over and
over and over and over so I just got
this product I'm in love I would highly
recommend that whole account and they
only show up on threads that are
specifically talking about this brands
product so I was like [ __ ] hell
there's no way I just so I put these
dots together screenshot and everything
show Jenna she was like holy [ __ ] I was
dying I pulled the plug on the
interactions I was basically like thank
you but no thank you
I'd rather not you know do business with
a company that you know it has practices
like that and they responded and kind of
played the dumb card like oh I don't
know that must have been one of our old
agents or representatives meanwhile by
the time they responded all the things
are deleted that's crazy I just pulled
off some plugin but it's wild like when
you talk about like viral marketing or
people who work for companies and they
make jokes about every time on reddit
where it's like there's a post to the
front page about that's featuring some
brand my joke is like oh nice like GG's
like junior like employee yeah like nice
viral marketing but it's true it exists
it's like a real thing yeah well there
was one episode of like Hell's Kitchen
ders
something with Gordon Ramsay and this
family was like so terrible and they
were accused of going on their own Yelp
and reviewing it really positively and
then like bullying everyone that wrote
my consecutive review and like on their
Facebook to the woman would like
personally respond to them and like this
was a really bad experience for me and
they would attack that person yeah so
like I think you know it obviously
exists I don't think it's too completely
unheard of that someone would just like
pay their cousin or something be like
yeah write me a glowing review you know
because that stuff holds water like when
you read about a restaurant or you know
a product the reviews matter and then
you know it's up to your own discretion
whether or not you'd like to purchase
yeah plus I feel like sometimes it's
really helpful too because if if
someone's like I didn't like it because
you know there was it was broken there
was a return policy might be different
than someone's like the whole thing is
broken it's a bad design you know
whatever but whatever team it was really
I could I just couldn't believe it
hopefully I didn't give too much away I
don't know you're trying to drag anybody
no but that can't it can't possibly be
the first time that you know a company
is reaching out to people and is so
sketchy and I just can't believe they're
already username was literally their
name yeah I mean it's it's part of your
due diligence as someone if you're ever
gonna you know represent a company and
yeah it's not entirely your
responsibility or fault like if we had
taken the product right and everything
was good and then one of our fans was
like by the way I found this person like
secretly promoting this product and
claiming not to be part of their team I
would be like damn that's not a good
look I wish we don't I wish we didn't
associate that company but it would
media world yeah you would disassociate
but know it's important to do your
homework like just for example like that
because you'd be surprised at the the
practices that grown-ass adults take in
in their you know journeys to become
successful mm-hm for their company a
[ __ ] surprise man people do some
really
sneaky [ __ ] really yeah I mean just the
way they try to market products like
especially when it comes to influencers
like people are gnarly out there yeah I
don't do a lot of that period so I have
a limited experience but you see bad
stuff happen yeah when it comes to
brands and that whole like UK law or
something that they're passing that they
need to make it even more abundantly
overtly clear that these are
advertisements that these people were
compensated or because back in the
product back in the Wild West oh my god
there were no rules people were just
[ __ ] taking money under the table and
doing whatever and like there there were
times like back in you know 2010 11 12
when you would get emails from companies
being like we want you to set and I
think it's sometimes it still exists
like who knows what goes on in the
negotiations of these things like you
have to give us a positive glowing
review of our product and then you know
sometimes it wasn't even for money it
was just for the product itself and
you're just like [ __ ] is this like this
is so wrong but people did it you know
gnarly yeah well I mean now that like
the beauty community for example because
that's like what I would watch back in
the days I liked it you know I always
have but like when a new product would
come out like now it makes sense that
everyone wants to get their hands on it
they want to try it they want to test it
because they're excited you know and
these brands are you know I feel like
they play a bigger role in the beauty
community now than they did ten years
ago you know you we would go to a
drugstore or we barely even Sephora is
in a lot of places you know so he's just
whatever anyways it just felt like 10
years ago everyone all of a sudden had
the same product and all adored it and
you're like wow what am I missing I
really I guess I really gotta go get
this Holy Grail products like everyone
that I follow just loves it you know and
then you get it and you're like this
isn't even that good but there was no
one disclosing that they were at they
were all just getting paid out the ass
but [ __ ] no I don't know how like retro
actively they go back and like you know
that's like you watching now but and a
commercial comes on and Jamie Lee Curtis
is just eating yogurt and she's like
honestly what's up I'm Jamie Lee Curtis
I [ __ ] love this yogurt and then
commercials over and you're like I was a
weird video that played and it wasn't a
commercial you're like wait that sounded
like a commercial you know I mean but
like everyone knows what that feels like
when someone that you like to follow is
like using something in you're like oh I
wonder what that is like oh that looks
nice I really like her this or her that
you know wonder where she got that yeah
and you're just carry it just you know
stuff cells like that yeah but like it's
just so [ __ ] like nobody had to say
[ __ ] it's crazy
well now I mean there's there's also now
this like weird kind of like gray area
where if you get free product but you're
not getting paid what is that you know
because I I've partake partaking in that
I've gotten free things I got a free
package from impossible burger and most
times that I get it if not all times I'm
just like I got this sent to me by them
I don't know
you know I'm that's what happened yeah I
didn't go buy this in the store I'm
honest about that but at the same time
there are I've heard about things where
you could get in trouble if you get X
amount of product and you don't disclose
how it ended up in your hands yeah and
you just act like it's natural which is
not mmm-hmm because not natural to get a
PR package it's just not like it's a
calculated move with the desired
specific outcome and that's what the
outcome you're watching it's like some
of the video or whatever so I don't know
[ __ ] is wild I don't know how we even
got here I don't know dude we're being
just like the off the pill podcast where
they just talk about things and then
they moving on we're trying to be like
them they'd be like that and then we'd
be like I don't know why or how you
started seeing that so much you like
well I'd be like be like and then like a
caveman that'd be funny keep talking I
your be like yeah well yeah total
package did you just point to yourself
and call yourself a total package though
why as you speak like a caveman yes yes
correct
yes dude we're talking about magicians
and having a magician app oh yeah can we
make yeah I want to think a lot of hours
into something that really only if I'm
allowed for your next birthday to just
have one after another after another
magicians perform for you while your
health
magic hostage I want to be held magic
console around on my birthday as
possible
I don't want magicians that's what I
feel like I don't care people make fun
of me or whatever like I just love
having like a nice quiet nothing time
for my birthday oh yeah I'm gonna have
friends but absolutely don't prefer
having strangers around me on my
birthday yeah I feel that I'm good hmm I
think it's the one day where I can just
be like no be like yeah would you be mad
at me if I hired you a bunch of yeah
what about just like fun performers a
mine maybe I can find a mine for you I
don't want them anywhere near me I'm
gonna like deck out the backyard where
it's just like performance city
population you so I'm gonna set you down
in a chair and they're gonna start
performing for you one by one and I'm
gonna leave go into the other room and
just relax
because my work is done wait so you're
not even an agent this is just me you
know I'm not gonna watch that I'm
getting performed at yeah I'm not gonna
watch it no no is the answer my
birthday's coming up you know the first
day
would you be mad happy if I got you one
magician yes okay does anyone wanna
perform for Julian's but you won't be a
lot of you won't be allowed I'm not
gonna let you in if you don't book
through the app you'd okay okay also
with the app I get a 10% commission on
every single magician anyone ever hires
period that sounds illegal
ma that's my app I can make the rules I
really would agree to that if Joe Schmoe
out in Wisconsin orders a magician for
Joe schmo's and nephews birthday and
they pay clown Schmo however much I get
10% that that doesn't sound right
I put them together I don't think you
did I build the algorithm with my own
brain Thank You Billy
I did you know what thought should be
called brain writing brain rewriting
yeah that's my brain writing can you
read my brain writing like you can tell
that's what my thoughts like he reads
someone's handwriting you're like oh I
know that who wrote that if I say a
thought or I say something oh dude
that's totally Julian's brain writing
burp into the mic after you say
something
look can you read my brain writing can
you no I can't
I literally can't understand it was the
time you'll learn I was asking you if I
can get you a magician from Earth then
what about a clown
do you like clowns no why not I did when
I was a kid I don't hate them I'm not
like I don't have this fear of clowns a
lot of people do I just don't like them
they're funny no way
Cirque du Soleil clowns are so funny
that is not a clown
that is a performer and this always is a
circus don't put them in the same
sentence clown Oh dare you how literally
dare you there's clowns in it
no there's makeup and high high level
performers hi there high in the air
that's the level they perform it up I'm
telling you that there is a high level
in their industry and they're physically
high in the air at altitude high high
level performers what's the difference
between a Cirque du Soleil clown in a
regular clown
I don't know what's the difference
between Walmart and Chanel sorry was
that rude sorry all my clown guys out
there I know I have nothing against
console I mean Cirque du Soleil is
literally the MLB and clowns are weekend
softball with a keg behind second base
oh my god what you're still doing the
same thing one's at a professional level
my name is drunk wrong I'm sure there's
plenty of really good amateur clowns
there's plenty of really good amateur
softball players who kick back on the
weekends and go play with their friends
who hit absolute bomb come on that's not
wrong so just because they don't work
for Cirque de Soleil that makes them
lesser clowns I'm sorry but circus Olay
those guys are literally the top of the
top yes so you agreed that they're
clones don't trap me here I'm not
calling them clowns but if you want me
to associate them in the same so you
agree you think you're really pretty
grab some sleeves right now no no I want
to you can't say no to what that I'm
just telling you that's my thought
that's my brain writing you can't say no
to my brain ready it's like rain raining
Cirque du Soleil has clowns I write I
write brain writing in cursive I can't
read that it's too messy okay go on what
about our clowns I'm I know you're just
playing devil's advocate but there's no
way anyone could say that Cirque de
Soleil is full of clowns look it up no
no the performers like the balance
artist and the aerial [ __ ]
trampoline artists all of those those
are the performers there are clowns that
are in the middle of the X I don't even
they're closed I think it's almost I
think it's demeaning oh my god all right
have you ever seen Cirque de Soleil yeah
absolutely didn't how did you not see
the clown I saw I saw clown makeup on
some of the performers but I didn't see
a clown because I don't think amidst the
Las Vegas Cirque du Soleil show I was
close
okay party oh my god Cirque du Soleil
clown clowns
there's hole performances of them 182
dislikes that's how many people realize
you shouldn't call them clowns they're
clones
I'm not trying to be funny they
literally do like the funny stuff in
between the acts hello this is what I
was referring to I wasn't calling like
the women that do those incredible
[ __ ] actors loud there's the
misunderstanding I thought you're
calling the acrobats clowns no I get it
there was actually literal clowns who
come out and do funny that's what I said
they're so funny who did you think it
was laughing at fair enough I'll take
the El or that one I'll take the El I'll
take the clown with a capital L see L on
her forehead all right fair enough
speaking of circus alight we should go
to a show sometime I love Cirque de
Soleil it's so fun
mmm-hmm the last one that I went to was
here I think really Staples Center uh no
like the Chinese Theater or something
like that that's cool yeah it was like
at least five or six years of those no
it's pretty dope and then they went to
one in Boston you went to multiple yeah
they have all kinds of different shows
like they're always different I know
they're always different but that's so
cool you got to go to multiple we should
just go to one sometime yeah
don't touch my since there was a hair on
him okay I'm getting this hair off of
the weird dog that somehow ends up in
your lap every podcast
he's my sweet boy he deserves to sit
where he wants oh you know what's funny
we met someone this weekend really nice
dude who came up and was saying hi to us
and said he watched the podcast and he
liked one of the things he said that I
have never heard anyone say to me about
the podcast is y'all have different
backgrounds every week and I was like
yeah we do but it also got maybe you
think like I don't know if if you all
like like it or we could just make like
a Jenna Julianne thing I don't know yeah
well I mean someday if we need to use
this room for something other than
we might have to build like a little
green screen yeah the green screen is
fine and [ __ ] but yeah I mean evangelism
I'm saying setup it is and the like the
main reason we even need the lights is
to light the green screen so we wouldn't
even need all these huge lights if we
didn't use look at us making a giant
[ __ ] mess
who let us do this you oh oh yeah
everything's my fault
oh man you want trade mics for a sec why
our mics are grabbing sleeves yeah you
know what happens when we switch see
people get very upset
mmm what's your favorite like show that
you've seen in person stomp
I saw stop to hop was rad it's on my
favorite good stomp was one of my favor
I saw blue man group and I saw stomp I
saw Michael Jackson show the other one
because I was trying to convince Julian
to listen to some Riverdance music cuz
he's never seen Riverdance
Riverdance was the [ __ ] I don't blame
you it was so [ __ ] good and electric
and imagine it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool
you've never even seen it no I said the
music you showed me was pretty cool yeah
but have you seen Riverdance
no I still since the last day you asked
me which was less than a week ago I
still have not watched it samba school
um what else have I seen Oh Book of
Mormon like ten years ago I saw in New
York and it had you know who it hadn't
it feel like an [ __ ] because I'm
forgetting his name but he's in girl's
our favorite character Elijah
yes he was he was doing the lead and I
think that's one of his early big
Broadway
this is [ __ ] River
[ __ ] is [ __ ] wild when you're
sitting in there and you hear all the
Irish music and the Irish [ __ ]
dancing in their shoes they slap it on
the ground it's [ __ ] crazy
okay it sounds sick look at them no I
see it it's pretty dope okay I got both
legs it's pretty cool
damn like imagine being eight and being
this audience going wow that was me
okay we didn't have the Internet we're
gonna get cut ribbon it and we can buy
this CD on the way out so we can listen
to it again
you need to stop yelling review in the
paper
tiny mine I feel like I have a tiny mind
after that neighbor's dogs bark okay
it's okay I can't hear anything you say
now but it's okay so we it's a show it's
a live show and they're still out there
performing during intermission it's just
as intermission they keep dancing it's
just like many refrigerant go on
not to be rude or anything but I have
subpoenas like that's why a little bit
those guys are relentless absolutely
absolute mad lads out there
Riverdance tour let me see if they still
Oh Riverdance official tights our site
by the way I have to say this we talked
about getting me an adult Bar Mitzvah
I got emailed by a rabbi oh wait you did
it's only in Dublin and come on let's go
to Dublin
well we [ __ ] up man we were there one
time number fifteen twenty nineteen is
my birthday
Dublin yeah let's go dumpling I love
Dublin VIP experience what that means
you get to dance alongside them from
stage left behind the curtain
experiences you just get to go backstage
before the show and they kick you in the
face okay wait so an a rabbi emailed you
about having oper yeah damn that's sick
well they emailed us they emailed the
podcast Imam and they were like just so
you know it's possible you wouldn't need
to go to any school you could read this
certain you know I don't even know I'm
not gonna even say the terms cuz I don't
know what it's called but you read the
the readings you need to do and you need
to perform whatever but I could get it
done so it's it's a thing like that's
pretty cool it's kind of cool I don't
know would you ever be interested in
doing that honestly I think maybe I
would have to look into it like I I
don't know a lot of like what I feel
like I should know before making that
decision so I'm gonna do a little
research but I was saying because I was
talking about this on stream the other
day that when you get bar Mitzvahed or
bought miss food it's like the coming of
age so your become an adult mm-hmm so
you're not there no as I've never been
by misses I'm technically in the Jewish
religion still a child I'm still I'm
still a child
so if I ever want to grow up maybe we
make a video about me getting an adult
Bar Mitzvah I think it'd be a good video
I think more than anything I would do it
for the video which makes me
myself but I think it's funny well it
wouldn't be outrageous we could just do
something nice for you
well no I just yeah it's like an I'll
get you a cake I don't want cake I'll
get you a king I want a phone booth full
of cash flowing around that's what all
the bar mitzvahs have an outro that's
what they had when I grew up they all
had phone booths for you gone and it
starts to get windy and then you can
have the cash and you're like [ __ ] you I
guess yeah they so [ __ ] dead a lot of
them were just like those like that
insane [ __ ] you saw I got MTV but it was
like the kid that lived on the street
like that's it you 13 absolutely yeah
stacks for very little reason to get
that much money I'm not doing anything
like that John have your family over to
the house and we'll have a nice little
big gathering for you not getting you a
phone flying cat understand the cash is
a big ass okay so I'll downgrade it can
I just get a phone booth with pad thai
flying everywhere so I walk in there and
you turn it on and then there's just had
tiny needles flying everywhere and I'm
just like living my goddamn life
honestly that would be amazing but
logistical II know that wind would have
to be going so hard to me we need to
strap that Yama kind of my [ __ ] head
so it does not fly off and they need to
open my mouth to get that Pad Thai god
that's so disgusting what I just
described what that [ __ ] pump we could
buy Pad Thai sitting in the bottom of
I'll tell you one thing I'll tell you
one thing I hope the cleanup crew enjoys
Thai food because they are eating good
you I'm gonna be good I'm gonna be
counting my pad thai in cash I don't
know I'm just gonna I'm a man now I need
a working party
thing up anyway I could pursue that we
decided you're gonna have to do little
soul-searching and decide if you'd like
to become a Jewish man you know yeah
mm-hmm
salt certian salt and pepper searching
okay I don't how did we get peppers here
yeah I'll do some soul patch searching
Julian by myself that's where did it go
oh there it is I'm done so fast
searching well this whole podcast is
just literally about nothing so it's fun
oh this is the best I think it is Kermit
you want to take us out bud alone I love
you Kermit he's so handsome bud
all right to him good boy good boy
well thank you guys for listening to our
I just want to test to see if the mic
was working podcast we'll be back next
week with another episode the music's
playing right now so I don't sound as
horribly dry as I hear myself currently
so hope you guys have a wonderful week
and we'll catch you on the flippety-flip
bye
you
[Music]